thank you
all right Cub I'm skipping the intro
today and we're gonna max out the time
here uh this morning president Trump was
on Hugh Hewitt's radio show and uh Hugh
asked him about firing fauci and Trump's
exact quote was you're not allowed to
fire him I suspect you probably have a
different take on what you can do with
these civil servants like fauci sure
well first of all it's important to
point out for a long time that was not
his excuse his excuse had been that if
you fired fauci both the Democrats and
the media would have pitched a fit which
of course is a hundred percent true uh
but that's the price of leadership you
got to stand up and do what's right
um clearly he could have been fired from
the White House task force there was no
obligation to run him out at press
conference after press conference have
him doing media interviews you know
during the the height of kind of the
coveted stuff in 2020 fauci would do
local hits in Florida media attacking me
for having schools open and some of
these other stuff so there was no
obligation to do that I think you could
have also fired him from NIH because he
had basically committed uh misconduct
with the gain of function you also had
him saying that it was naturally
occurring when they knew it was a lab
leak all that stuff has come out now so
I think yes you fire him and here's the
thing Dave
if it's the right thing to do you do it
if they sue you they sue you but you had
the basis to do that and you should have
done it and the country would have been
better off had he done it so I want to
talk a bit more about Trump in a moment
but it does seem like in the last couple
days that covet is coming back somehow
They're bringing covid back or they want
us to think kovid's back whoopee on The
View has kovid now Dr Jill Biden has
coveted uh Florida clearly is Ground
Zero from uh for protecting the people
from government overreach what would you
be doing right now for the rest of the
country if you were president
cleaning out the CDC NIH FDA all these
agencies that failed US during covid we
need a reckoning for what they did to
this country and yes in Florida we
fought back against it there were other
states like what Kim Reynolds did in
Iowa to make sure kids were in school
and to push back but there are parts of
this country that were really really
harmed because of the fouchism and yet
they were wrong about lockdowns they
were wrong about Force masking they were
wrong about school closures they were
wrong about mRNA vaccines and yet
nobody's been held accountable and it's
my view that until there's
accountability they're going to keep
trying it again I mean the notion that
you have a school district in the D.C
suburbs I think Montgomery County
imposing masks in 2023 shows that you
give these people an inch they're going
to take a mile so we need that
accountability we are going to bring
Reckoning we are going to turn those a
agencies inside and out we need people
we don't need fouchies running around
those agencies we need people like my
Surgeon General in Florida Dr Joseph
latapo who was right against the
lockdowns he was right against the force
masking from day one that's what we need
we need people like Dr bhattacharya from
Stanford so I think they're going to
keep trying this in Florida we've
enacted permanent protection so you
can't force anybody to wear a mask you
can't force kids to mask in school you
can't close businesses none of that we
saw that this would be something that
would likely happen in the future and so
we put in permanent protections but that
should be the order of the day
throughout this country so
accountability for what happened and
just think about it not only did you
infringe Freedom not only did you lie
about things like vaccines the federal
government went additional six trillion
dollars in debt over covid and with a
with the response that's more debt than
we racked up in like the first 200 years
of this country and yet people don't
want to talk about it the only person
that stood up at the time was
Congressman Thomas Massey and he was
pilloried but he was right so we are
going to have a reckoning when I'm the
president I know you've tried to take
the high road when when some of these
Trump attacks are coming your way but
when he goes off on Florida and the
coveted response it implies that somehow
New York did a better job or something
like that
um I mean do you want to hit him harder
I understand you're running a campaign
and you're running a state but but what
do you think the policy should be on
this sort of thing because in some ways
it seems like a no-win situation
I think honestly I think he hurts
himself nobody in the Republican base
thinks co uh New York handled covet
better than Florida nobody believes that
it's not believable and in fact he
doesn't believe it because he said for
years how good Florida did he said I was
one of the great governors in America
all of this stuff off was kind of gospel
nobody ever questioned it until about
three days before the midterm elections
he saw that I was fixing to win a
landslide and he started attacking me
and then that's basically it just
because he believes that I'm a threat to
his Ambitions that's the only reason
he's saying this uh if he didn't believe
that he wouldn't be saying any of it so
it's obviously bogus I mean half the
country visited Florida over covet and
you're trying to say California New York
and Illinois handled it better give me a
break so sometimes I think you know you
want you you should be responding but I
think sometimes like the more he does
that I think it helps me because I kind
of wish like he had broader reach with
some of his social media because I think
just putting that stuff out there I
think it hurts his credibility uh more
than anything especially because he's on
the record saying how good a job we've
done in Florida in the past and
especially because his entire family
moved to Florida under my governorship
yeah what's your message to the ride or
die Trump people like that the hardcore
Maga base that before all of this they
loved you but they're just going with
Trump but you know that you have to get
some of those people to win this thing
well nobody in in the United States in
the Republican party has delivered more
on America First policies and principles
than me if you look at immigration
illegal immigration we've banned
Sanctuary cities we've cracked down on
human smuggling we even sent illegal
aliens to beautiful Martha's Vineyard uh
and so we've put our money where our
mouth is you talk about things like
China we've banned the purchase of land
by the CCP and its Affiliates in our
state we got rid of things like
Confucius institutes and we crack down
on their influence of universities you
look at what we've done for expand
second amendment rights with
constitutional carry look at what we've
done to fight against the woke agenda
whether it's fighting Disney involving
education or fighting this e SG movement
which is really bad for our economy and
for American families the way they're
going after domestic energy production
you want to talk about draining the
swamp there's one guy in this entire
country that's ever taken action against
soros-backed prosecutors and that's me
and we've removed two of them from
office in the last year year and a half
who were not following the law and were
putting their political agenda over
Public Safety I cleared out the election
supervisors in South Florida when I
became Governor we've banned Zucker
bucks we've banned ballot harvesting we
have Universal voter ID and we even have
an election crimes task force police
force in state government which which
prosecutes voter front so we have the
best election Integrity in the entire
country so I think in terms of
delivering on these things nobody's
delivered more than I have and
everything I promised the voters I I
would do I've delivered on and exceeded
those promises and so you've got a guy
like me going in there you know you'll
have two terms of somebody uh that that
the people in Washington do not want to
see up there the corporate press does
not want to see me up there and the
Democrats don't want to see me up there
because they realize I don't just say
this stuff in a campaign season when I
tell you I'm going to do something I
follow through and I do it is that the
weird thing about your campaign at the
moment that in some ways Trump and the
mainstream media are on the same side
when it comes to you and that is some
seriously strange bedfellows yeah well I
mean you know you you were in Milwaukee
uh for that debate the night before the
debate Trump's main campaign operatives
were whining and dining corporate
journalists from NBC New York Times
Washington Post all these Outlets that
he had always always said were the enemy
of the American people and yet they're
colluding to basically try to put dirt
out on me and I think that they've
developed left a really unhealthy
symbiotic relationship because the
corporate press wants Trump to be the
nominee partially because he's better
for Ratings but partially because they
think that means the Democrats will win
and they don't want me to be the nominee
because they know I will run better
Biden ragged around this country beat
him but more importantly than that they
know I will actually convert on all this
stuff they want to see America continue
to decline I mean that's what they they
want they don't want to see a guy like
me come in reverse that Decline and put
us on a better path so they're doing
everything they can to try to shape the
battlefield accordingly but they work
very closely with some of Trump's
henchmen to put out as much dirt on me
as they can now the stuff they put out
is ridiculous but they do it and they do
it a lot and it just shows you you know
who they who they perceive as the threat
is it tough for you personally to hear
some of the nonsense I mean from I feel
like I've gotten to know you fairly well
and it seems like it just kind of rolls
off your back but when you when you see
the really crazy stuff that that he's
throwing at you does does it ever bother
you or or the first lady or anything I
think we both just understand one it
goes with the territory to they're
shooting at you because you're over the
target that's just the nature of it um
and then three I think some of it's so
ridiculous that I just think people are
smart enough to know uh that it's a
bunch of bull and I think that they just
discount it they understand this as
political Silly Season I mean you just
do it now look I mean I think um you
know there's um uh there are some folks
uh out there online or whatnot that that
kind of excuse some of the nonsense
whereas if the shoe were on the other
foot they'd be singing a different tune
but that's fine we get that um but at
the end of the day what what are we
going to do we're not going to fight the
good fight because we're worried about
someone may something say something mean
about us I mean what I always tell
people is in this day and age when
you're standing for what's right it's
not going to be cost free our country
wouldn't be in the state it's in if
doing what was right was easy you go out
there I mean you have moms going to
school board meetings they're getting
attacked by the media they're being
surveilled by the FBI so leadership
comes with a cost there is a cost to
standing for what's right in this day
and age and the way I view it is
whatever I'm having to do in terms of
taking that type of incoming that's a
that's not even in the same universe as
what people uh in Prior Generations have
had to do to preserve our freedom and
you can just see that just try visiting
Arlington National Cemetery you see
people that gave the last full measure
of devotion for service of the country
so you're not going to see me whining
about somebody calling me names let's
try to hit as many big topics as we can
in the time remaining one thing that I
keep hearing from people and when I was
in Milwaukee a few people did say it to
me they want to hear you expand on the
Ukraine situation more uh that it's at
first sounded like you you gave that
statement to Tucker worker that felt
more isolationist than maybe you pulled
back on that a little bit I know we have
only a certain amount of time yeah you
want to lay that out a bit yeah sure I
mean what they said was I was asked
after that whether I thought Putin was a
good guy and I said of course not but
that doesn't mean that we should be
writing a blank check uh with no uh
concept of what our interests are or
what the victory is uh so we've been
pretty consistent actually on all this
uh we need to end this war no blank
check Europe needs to step up uh and
anything we do should be in America's
national interest you don't subcontract
out your national interests to other
countries and I don't think it's been in
our interest to be sending money to pay
pensions for Ukrainian bureaucrats and
salaries for Ukrainian bureaucrats so
what I would do as president I would use
the leverage that we have available to
us to bring the conflict to an end in a
way that this isn't going to continue to
be an issue for the next 50 years 60
years I mean just think with Biden his
energy policy is benefiting Russia it's
fueling their ability to to wage war in
the first place it's benefiting Iran he
just gave Iran 6 billion what is Iran
doing with that money partially they're
sending to Russia uh to help uh Russia
China he wants us to be more dependent
on China they're obviously benefiting
Russia so you can turn all of those
leverage points on but then also use the
leverage that we have with our European
allies say guys this is your continent
um you know when this thing comes in
let's bring this in for a landing and
then you guys have to step up and meet
your security obligations and part of
what animates that is I think our
primary National Security objective is
to deter China and if we want to do that
we're going to have to do a lot more uh
to project hard power in the
indo-pacific than we've been doing I
think Biden views the top challenge is
Europe I think he views China as a
client not as an adversary I view China
as an adversary and I think they're the
only ones in this world that could
possibly compete with us on a global
scale
what do you make of the the polling data
right now I know you don't govern
bipolars I've heard you say it many
times but if we're to believe the polls
you know somehow Trump is at 50 or yeah
look I think I mean I I think that you
know some of these primary polls are
what they are I mean you know you
followed my re-election race there were
polls that had me up by one or two
points and I won by you know almost 20
points and so sometimes when you have
this volume of polls clearly polls are
expensive and so if you're doing them
every day you know either someone's
funding that with an agenda or not but I
also understand you know you're running
against somebody who is a hundred
percent name identification probably the
most famous person uh in the modern
history of politics uh but what I think
that that it shows and I think we have
data after the debate to show this is
that you know whatever he's at he's got
some that are very hard for him for sure
and then he's got a lot that are soft
and those are people that you know
they're willing to to support somebody
that's strong that has a record of
delivering on America First principles
and that would be a a big time a change
agent as president they are not going to
vote for somebody who's just going to go
back and be a managed decline Republican
so if it's a choice between Trump or
that they are going to go Trump but when
they're presented with my bio my family
my accomplishments and our vision you
know we do convert those people now
we're having to do this on the ground
going town to town in Iowa town to town
in New Hampshire and we've actually had
a huge amount of success in Iowa I mean
if you look back at previous election
cycles and find where the Iowa caucus
winner was in the summer people like Ted
Cruz and Santorum they were pulling at
like five or six percent you know we're
clear second in Iowa under any metric
everybody else is in single digits and
so I wouldn't trade places with anyone
in Iowa right now I think we're doing
what we need to do and we are going to
outwork everybody in those early States
but once that starts to happen that's
what's going to make the big difference
so everything we're doing is geared
towards accumulating delegates if we
were trying to juice National polls then
you know we would try to advertise
nationally and do some of those things
and so it's a state by state thing
that's what we're doing and we're happy
with the progress we've made
particularly over the last I think four
to six weeks I think we've uh you know
we've solidified a lot of support and
we're building
do you want Trump to show up to the next
debate I mean the last one was a little
bizarre because you were clearly the
front runner at the debate and nobody
was going after you and I I bumped into
you in the hotel the next morning and
you said well they knew I was going to
hit back and it seems like they were
sort of afraid you know Vivek a little
bit I suppose uh but it seems like they
didn't want to go after you so the
Dynamics are really bizarre right now
yeah I mean look I think he owes it to
the to the public to debate I think the
the idea that he's entitled to be
nominated is absurd I think that there's
a lot of questions that he needs to
answer uh both about how he would win
the election uh but also about some of
the decisions that he made as president
you pointed out the fauci and then there
are others so I think he should do it he
probably won't do it uh and that's fine
I'm going to be there regardless I do
think you're going to see a smaller
stage because I think some of those
folks aren't going to qualify for this
next round and look my thing is is you
know it's far be it for me to tell
anyone who to run or not run but you
either have a path or you don't and if
you don't have a path then we should
focus on the candidates you know that
have a that have a conceivable shot at
this um I will say though being on that
stage I think one of the reasons why
um you know I wasn't necessarily the
target as much as people thought is I
have a record of success uh I've done
the things that people are talking about
that we need to do for this country in
Florida across the board and so I'm
armed with the ability to say that I've
done it and also to point out you know
whatever shortcomings would be from
somebody that's lobbing a grenade my way
so I'm prepared to do however it shakes
out but if it's just me and I get
something I want to look into the camera
and tell people my vision of how to
reverse this country's decline beat
Biden and get us on a better path and
and I think we all know we need to do
that I'm the one guy that has a record
of showing how it can be done with how
we've transformed Florida let me ask you
just two more uh as you know I'll have
you on this show anytime but personally
I want to see you on The View I want to
see you sit down with those ladies have
them repeat that hysterical nonsense
Anna what's her name who lives in
Florida and says crazy things about this
state do you plan on going for those
fights a little bit more because to me
that that's where you shine and I think
that that's what people want to see out
of you yeah we might I mean I think we
have done some of the the more corporate
press uh you know with like the NBCS and
the cnns uh so you may see I mean look I
think uh you know the View kind of the
the hysterical stuff that they've put
out it's uh it can be a little bit much
at times but uh but who knows you know
we we may end up doing that but you know
I'm out and about when we do our
campaign stuff anyone can come and ask
us questions uh we welcome that you know
we've got the the typical corporate
Outlets uh that follow us around
so my last question for you is going to
be for my mom my mom who is a lifelong
Democrat but she has woke up to the
insanity of the Democrats she knows how
I feel about Florida and that I've
supported you but the idea of voting for
a republican still in her mind is is
tough what would you say to that person
who's who's about to break they've had
it with the Democrats they've had it
with the woke but the idea of really
making that move even though they
part-time live in Florida is a tough one
what what's the sales pitch right there
well well first I would just say I kind
of understand that you know my
grandmother lived until she was 91 in
Western Pennsylvania uh you know her
husband my grandfather was a steel
worker and she never voted for a
republican for any office in her entire
life and basically she was you know
traditional catholic had conservative
views on a lot of things but it was like
she said look the the Republicans are
only for the rich the Democrats are for
the working people and I would just say
that I think the parties are really
changing and who they represent I think
the Democratic party they're driven by
an elite ideology I mean woke ideology
ultimately that's something that came
out of places like Berkeley and these
left-wing institutions this is not like
salt of the earth ideology these are
Elites trying to cram this down your
throat trying to tell you know your
kindergartner daughter that that she's
actually a boy that is not anything that
has ever sprung up from kind of the the
salt of the earth so I think what we're
doing at least me as a republican what I
conceive of my role is to represent
Common Sense again a restoration of
Sanity in this country and to do like
what we did in Florida you know you
can't please everyone Dave but we took
very strong stands and we won 60 40. I
can tell you 60 percent of the voters
are not Republicans in Florida it's
closer to like 36 percent so we had to
get independence and some Discerning
Democrats to say you know what we can't
have an open border we have to have
security we can't have crime running the
streets we have to have the rule of law
we need an economy so people can afford
gas and afford a home and afford
groceries again we need these core
things of parents rights to ensure
parents are involved with education
those are things I think that span party
lines and that I think we can build a
strong movement behind and it's really
just restoring the country to a sense of
sanity
all right we're clipping that and
sending it to my mom thanks gov we'll
see you on the trail all right God bless
take care
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell